me dicen aplica la propiedad
distributiva para expandir la expresión
y tengo esta expresión que tengo aquí
ahora para resolver este ejercicio voy a
copiar esto que tengo aquí y lo voy a
pegar en mi pizarrón justo aquí y
entonces tengo un medio que multiplica a
2 a menos 6 ven más 8 y para divertirnos
un poco más voy a copiar exactamente lo
mismo pero lo voy a poner con colores me
va a quedar un medio esto que a su vez
multiplica a 2 y lo voy a poner con este
color que multiplica a 2 am - 6 b
entonces aquí voy a poner un signo de
menos y me va a quedar con este color
voy a poner a 6 ven ya esto hay que
sumarle 8 entonces con este color voy a
poner el signo además y voy a poner que
vamos a sumarle ahora con este color voy
a poner
muy bien entonces tengo un medio que
multiplica a esta expresión y lo que
quiero hacer es distribuir este un medio
eso quiere decir que voy a multiplicar
este un medio por toda esta expresión o
dicho otra manera voy a multiplicar este
un medio por cada uno de estos términos
es decir voy a multiplicar a esto en
medio por este término
voy a multiplicar a éste un medio por
este término y voy a multiplicar a este
un medio por este otro término entonces
me va a quedar lo siguiente déjame
apuntarlo aquí en esto va a ser igual a
quien bueno voy a tener un medio déjame
poniendo así
medium que va a multiplicar primero a 2
am lo voy a copiar con su respectivo
color va a multiplicar a 2 am dejame
cerrar el paréntesis y después a esto
hay que quitarle hay que quitarle un
medio un medio lo voy a poner con su
respectivo color y todo esto para que
sepas de donde sale cada cosa un medio
que multiplica a 6 b que lo voy a poner
con color azul 6 ven muy bien voy a
cerrar el paréntesis voy a poner este
signo además aquí y por último también
vamos a multiplicar a este 8 por un
medio y entonces me va a quedar un medio
que multiplica a 8 que lo voy a poner
con su respectivo color justo así y
bueno toda esta expresión a que va a ser
igual esto va a ser igual a bueno cuanto
es un medio por 2 a bueno primero un
medio por 2 es lo mismo que 1
y uno por ahí me va a quedar simplemente
a am - y después tengo un medio por 6 b
ahora un medio por 6 bueno eso es lo
mismo que 33 enteros por ver me voy a
quedar simplemente 3 b
3b y por último tengo un medio por 8
entonces voy a poner este signo además y
aquí tengo un medio por 8 bueno eso es
lo mismo que 8 medios que es exactamente
igual que cuatro enteros muy bien así
que me quedan a menos 3 b más 4 esa es
mi respuesta a menos 3 ven más 4 vamos a
recordarlo porque lo voy a escribir aquí
en mi respuesta
- tres veces más
4 y observa es literalmente la mitad de
estos términos si observas la mitad de 2
am es a la mitad de 6 b es 3 ver con ese
signo negativo y la mitad de 8 es 4 así
que ya está tengo aquí mi respuesta y es
momento de revisar si estamos bien
de lujo estamos bien así que vamos a
resolver uno más bien ahora tenemos este
de aquí índice aplica la propiedad
distributiva para factorizar el máximo
común divisor de bueno estos dos y tengo
60 m menos 40 así que de nuevo lo voy a
copiar y lo voy a pegar justo aquí en mi
pizarrón vieron aquí está 60 m
40 así que déjenme copiarlos acá abajo
voy a trabajar con 60 m muy bien y por
otra parte acá tengo al 40 al 40 y
quiero encontrar entre estos dos el
máximo común divisor y bueno puede ser
que ten brinke que 10 es un divisor
porque ya sabes podemos ver a 60 m como
bueno 10 veces 6 10 veces 6 x bueno no
olvidemos por esta m y también podemos
ver al 40 de la siguiente manera el 40
es lo mismo que 10
a veces 4 y entonces el 10 es un factor
común pero 10 no es el máximo factor
común y como no se bueno porque si
observas este 6 que tengo aquí y este 4
que tengo aquí todavía tienen factores
en común y como lo sé bueno porque ambos
tienen mitad entonces recuerdan el
máximo común divisor o en este caso el
máximo como un factor que queremos
encontrar debe ser tal que lo que quede
ya no tenga factores comunes entre ellos
así que mejor déjame escribirlo así esto
lo vamos a ver de la siguiente manera 60
60 m
va a ser lo mismo que y bueno lo voy a
escribir de la siguiente manera 60 m va
a ser 20 veces bueno 20 meses 3 m porque
si multiplicas 3 m por 20 me va a dar 60
m
por otra parte 40 40 es lo mismo que 20
veces 220 veces 2 porque 2 por 20 es 40
y esto porque 3 m2 ya no tienen factores
en común entonces ya podemos decir que
factor izamos correctamente si todo esto
te parece un poco confuso o que sale por
arte de magia entonces podemos hacerlo
por pasos y pensar en el máximo común
divisor de la siguiente manera me voy a
tomar primero a 60 y por acá me voy a
tomar a 40 y lo que voy a hacer es
factorizar cada uno de estos dos en
primos y encontrar los factores que
tienen en común así que empecemos con
este 60 vamos a factorizar los primos si
a 60 le sacamos mitad bueno nos quedan
30 sea 30 le sacamos mitad bueno nos
quedan 15 15 bueno 15 ya no tiene mitad
pero tiene tercera así que le vamos a
sacar tercera
nos quedan 5 muy bien y ahora vamos a
hacer lo mismo con el 40 si al 40 le
sacamos mitad bueno nos quedamos con 20
sea 20 le sacamos mitad bueno nos
quedamos con 10 si a 10 le sacamos mitad
bueno nos quedaremos con 5 y ahora vamos
a atrapar todos los factores que
tengamos en común aquí tengo como factor
común un 2 lo voy a tratar también aquí
muy bien tengo por aquí otro 2 como
factor común también lo voy a tratar
aquí y bueno ya no tengo otro 2 pero
tengo un 5 un 5 más como factor común
observamos que de este lado solamente
voy a tomar 2 2 es y no me tomo estos 3
2 es porque del lado izquierdo solamente
tenemos dos veces 2 y bueno ya podemos
encontrar el máximo común divisor el
máximo común divisor es la
multiplicación de 2 por 2 por 5 2 por 2
es cuatro por 5 es
así que esta es la forma sistemática de
encontrar el máximo común divisor pero
bueno ya que tenemos el máximo común
divisor lo voy a apuntar aquí quedamos
que es 20 20 que multiplican y bueno
primero tengo que dividir a 60 m entre
20 lo cual me va a dar 3 m 3 m menos
menos y después tenemos que dividir 40
entre 20 y 40 entre 20
y ya con eso hemos acabado este
ejercicio así que vamos a ponerlo me va
a quedar
2020 que multiplica a 3m -2 muy bien lo
único que hicimos fue encontrar el
máximo común divisor y ahora observa que
3m y 2 son primos relativos primos
relativos significa que no comparten
factores en común distintos de uno y
ahora sí vamos a comprobar y de lujo
estamos bien